all right guys
bang bang i've got a special treat for
us today
i have my friend greg here uh greg's
done things on the internet for a long
time
what's up man uh not much i mean a lot
but not much looking forward to getting
into it
all right uh for those that don't know
you let's start with
uh you're from canada right all right
how
did when you get to the u.s and what was
your first foray into the tech world
um you know i don't really talk about
this much but maybe i'll give the the
real deal story on on here this is the
best time to do it this is why you come
on to just share the truth
okay i'll share the truth so i'm from a
city montreal canada
it's kind of like paris meets las vegas
in a lot of ways um and
uh you know it has one of the largest
internet companies no one's ever heard
of
it's called mind geek now mind geek
actually
is a monopoly on all of the adult
adult content so they own youporn
pornhub
browsers playboy digital that's all
owned by one company one holding company
it's also where a lot of gambling and a
lot of the gaming companies are based as
well in montreal
so you know i got my start really in the
underbelly of the internet
and that's where i really learned um
you know we would do deals like you know
as a teenager 13 14 15
it would be like adult friend finder
you'll pay us five dollars for every
lead we generate
and we basically used to buy traffic me
and my friends
and if we can spend four dollars to make
five dollars then we'd put you know
we'd go for ten dollars a day to 100 a
day to a thousand dollars a day to
you know and the numbers kept getting
bigger um
and i attribute like pretty much
everything i know about
human psychology and what being how do
you get people to do things to my early
days work
working in that space so uh
it's interesting to hear this i did not
know this
because most
of the best product people that i know
and you know we've got a lot of mutual
friends
at some point worked on growth type
products and that's essentially what you
were doing right you're just arbitraging
the cost of traffic for what somebody
else would pay you for it and you
figured out how to
essentially grow that traffic over time
and make money
and like that in essence is like what
every business should be doing right
it's like figuring out how do you make
something for less than you sell it for
right so it makes sense yeah it got me
thinking about like
businesses as vending machines and
you know if it costs four dollars to
make five it's like okay i want to put
more money in there
and i just
you know i learned a lot from that
experience also the difference between
you know having a you know a woman or a
man
look at look at you you know on the
landing page or if it's red hair or
brown
hair and if that's the difference if you
make 50 grand that day or at least 50
grand
that day you're gonna pay attention you
know so
those learns a lot got it and so at what
point do you decide to go from
working on that to actually building uh
various technology platforms or
companies
so after that i was kind of like i need
to get credibility
um you know i want to do so i basically
teamed up with
a few friends and and got into the
agency game
um and we designed a lot of stuff that
was like
you know cool you know at the time cool
like techcrunch.com and wordpress vips
product
and then we took some of that money and
we built our own startup so we built a
studio model this was in
this is like almost 15 years ago um
and that's when i realized um
[Music]
you know why am i building why am i
spending 100 of my time on client work
when i could actually build multiple
startups
so i did that um and we created a bunch
of startups
some of them got acquired um some of
them didn't work but
uh that's kind of what what like how i
got the startup bug
um and then after that you know i
started a company
um went to san francisco it was called
five buy
it was like uh sort of the at the time
there was
youtube was getting really big uh 2012.
there was you know millions of videos
being uploaded every day but people
needed sort of curation on top of it so
we built that platform
um and uh we sold that to stumbleupon
which at the time was one of the largest
um social networking apps so i joined
the management team there
um and uh and then after that i saw
i started islands which yeah what was
the experience
like working at stumbleupon when it was
so big and
just so powerful really yeah so
stumbleupon was started by gary kampf
actually
who's the co-founder of uber and
he had he had recently left when i
joined he's still on the board
um and you know
that experience working with that
caliber of a board
you know garrett camp samir gandhi who's
at excel
ram sharam who was on the board of
google he literally put like the first
dollars into google
um you know this was me like i had come
from
the underbelly really and i'm in silicon
valley now i'm like hanging out with all
these guys they're teaching me so much
and and stumbleupon was generating you
know a billion plus page views for
publishers
and i was able easily able to say like
oh hey like
buzzfeed let's generate 100 million page
we can generate 80 million pages to you
today you know 100 million page views so
there was a
that was a really cool experience um
but i think the big learning i had from
it was
if you're a social lab and you lose
steam
like you can't really come back from it
you know you don't often see consumers
so i can't think of one example of a
consumer social company
that became really big and then kind of
went down and then like became really
big again
i i actually can't think of a single one
that that's ever happened
right yeah yeah i can't i can't think of
one i think
you know social you just kind of have to
it's a growth game and you have to
continue growing you have to continue to
reinvent yourselves
um day after day and kind of always be
on the prowl
that like someone's gonna eat your lunch
and it's really momentum more than
anything like growth is a big piece of
it but the momentum
game of how are you going to keep the
growth and kind of keep
uh accelerating is a huge piece of it
and so all right so you do that
leave you decide that you're going to
start islands uh that's when we first
met
uh yeah and maybe talk a little bit
about like what you were trying to build
there and why
yeah um end of 2015
i'm like group chat is the new social
network
um it's going to verticalize um you're
gonna have a place
for um chat with your work
friends that was slack chat with your
gamer friends that ended up becoming
discord and in a bunch of different
verticals
i've always been into creating
communities in different verticals
um was on the board of the largest
cannabis media company in the world
um i you know one of the startups that
came out of the agency was one of the
largest financial education
communities in the world so like always
been like pick a vertical
learn how to grow it grow it and then in
my
in my experience sell it and get
acquired um
i saw this mass if i was like i was like
okay if group chat is the new social
network
where do i start um and
i you know was in san francisco i raised
two million dollars on
basically here's group chat as the new
social network and i said give me money
and i'll pick a vertical
and we ended up on the vertical of
college students because we were like
oh hey you know facebook started at
college
and there's no real easy way to like
open up an app and like
communicate with you know like-minded
people at college and
and see people around you and that's
what we did and
um you know it worked it worked
on one hand it worked we had between 5
and 25
penetration on every school we launched
that within 7 days
the average user would send 50 messages
every day
the average user would invite 2.1 people
so we had all the metrics
on the other hand what didn't work was
the timing sucked
you know now people care about social
and want to try new things and want to
download new apps
but you know fast forward to 2018 and it
was the lowest amount of venture capital
in social
since i think it was like 2002 right
after the internet bubble
and it just goes to show you that like
you can be right
and you could raise from the right
people and you could hire the right
people
hire the right people and you can do all
the right things
but if the market isn't in your favor
like that sucks
yeah and and i think part of this that
was really interesting to me is
uh the way you found the college campus
market
uh you let's say did things that maybe
other founders wouldn't be willing to do
and so talk a little bit about uh your
what was it six or twelve months uh
basically living on college campuses and
kind of what you were doing
yeah i mean you know my whole thing is
you know vertical networks right and if
you really want to get
to know a vertical you kind of have to
be at one with the vertical
you have to really embed yourself you
have done you have to really get to know
it and
you know i you know explained a bit of
my past now like i barely went to
college i went to mcgill
in canada but like i dropped out um
schools in the us are very different
than canada
or anywhere in the world for that matter
um
and we hired
you know you know one of the founding
team members of the
yak which was another popular social
network back in the day and but
i i still needed to be i needed to be
there so i said to myself i'm going to
spend six to 12 months
and literally go every school that we're
gonna launch ends
and speak to people and i'm like a 28
year old dude just like
walking around wearing like all black
and like you know
oxford mississippi and people are like
who the hell is that guy
and because that's where we started we
started in the south you know
i get the feeling that they're like hey
who's the old guy dressed in all black
i remember like i was i was actually in
oxford
and i was at you know end of the day
sitting at a bar
i just for whatever reason wearing a
black hat
you know black james purse shirt and
then these like black jeans with like
black john varvatos converse
shoes and i'm in this like bar and like
i was just on my
phone i look up and i just see like
everyone is like
it's like 80 mostly guys wearing like
polos
stretch up socks like you know didn't
fit in
and like people were looking at me but
like you know i think
i think that's what you have to do like
if you really care about
like crafting a business and trying to
understand and you have to
go there like i mean you know did i want
to be in oxford mississippi
like drinking a bud light you know
surrounded by like
80 80 dudes named chad and brad
um looking at me funny like absolutely
not but i
i wanted to win that's what ends up
happening
and uh ultimately what happens
ultimately what happens with the
business is
um i go out there to raise money um i
want to raise a lot of money
i get offered a little bit of money and
i was just like
all right i you know i'm a go big or go
home type of guy like all
in you know i didn't move to silicon
valley to
to like not go big on this
um and so i just reached out to 15
um potential acquirers and gotten you
know a few offers got the best one and
we sold to
to wework to basically power their
social networking experience
pre-ipo and i joined as a head of
product strategy there
so a lot of people don't know this but
what you just said
is a very difficult but wise decision
for founders which basically was
and i was privy to some of your thought
process at the time
uh so i can cheat here a little bit but
it takes a certain amount of capital
to do the things you need to do in order
to take something that was
you know starting to work into kind of
working to now hey you got to slam on
the gas and you've got to
drive that momentum to scale nationally
very quickly
right and that's basically the
inflection point you were at but it
takes capital
and so when you don't get that capital
there's kind of a
fork in the road you can either say hey
i'll take a small amount of capital and
i'll kind of do my best
or you basically say look i've got deep
conviction in what needs to happen here
and if i can't do that then
it doesn't make sense for me to pursue
this and by choosing the latter
i actually think it's a more responsible
thing to do
right because you're you're locking in
early investors getting a return
and not putting a new investors capital
at risk with a plan that you're not
necessarily convinced will work to some
degree
yeah that's exact i actually i was like
that's exactly how i felt i was like hey
like
if i raise an extra three million
dollars i'm not sure that the market
i have to ask myself do i think the
market is going to be better in 12
months or worse than 12 months or the
same
and i was like it's probably going to be
the same like the venture
the venture environment and when you're
a social app company
you need venture capital to survive and
to grow right we talked about in the
beginning you need to grow grow grow
so i was just like you know what if i
can get a return for my investors
um and my team
you know everyone on my team pretty much
bought
houses from the outcome of it you know
that makes
that makes me feel really good so um i
think that it's
it's something that you know one thing
founders should do is really like
understand who's who should like from
day one like
make okay you're starting a company
who's the who are the
um seven companies that would are gonna
buy your company and who are the three
people that you need to know
at that company you know they call it
the law of 21 how do you know how do you
get those 21 people and know them
from day one you start the company so
that you know for us like
selling the company was just a tech it
was just some texts
right it was like hey like we're selling
hey you know head of
product at xyz company we are selling
the company are you do you want to make
an offer
versus like trying to scramble
for like an intro and it's like
you know they don't know who you are and
you don't have that trust and
i see that's where i see a lot of
founders kind of struggle
yeah i completely agree uh you worked at
wework
wework had a uh incredible rise and
uh then had its infamous uh stretch
which you were there for
uh i know you can't say too much but any
kind of
thoughts or or lessons learned or
takeaways from uh the entire we work
experience
yeah yeah i was gonna say you know i can
write a book about it but i think a lot
of people are
um you know you you you learn the most
about yourself
people and
and companies when when when you're at
your high and when you're at
you're low and you know i think
you know i remember having a
conversation with garrett actually
um when you know he was on the board
gary kemp and he was on the board of
stumble and he was stumbleupon and he
was on the board of uber and i was like
what do you learn
more from uber or stumble upon and he
said
uh he said stumble upon him he was like
you learn more you learn more from your
downfall than your upfall and
you know your upswings he's like
everything is going right at at
uber so um i got i got a a chance to
to learn a lot about you know the ups
and downs from that
from that business um i got a chance to
learn
a lot from the softbank team and what
they did
and but you know
i don't want to learn for the rest of my
life
absolutely and so you recently left and
you started late checkout please
uh which one is a amazing name so i'll
have to talk about where kind of that
name came from
uh and so let's talk a little bit about
what you're planning to do now
and then i want to spend the rest of the
podcast talking through just every
business and startup idea that you and i
have ever had we're just gonna
open the uh the kitchen sink here and
kind of just dump them on people but
where did the idea for late checkout
police come from
and then what the hell is up with the
name
yeah i mean so okay
i'll take a step back um
[Music]
in a lot of ways i'd rather be a vc than
an entrepreneur
because you know you're you're all
in as an entrepreneur you're 100 and
basically
close to 100 your net worth is tied to
the outcome of this business and
i think it's that's actually a really
foolish way to
live your life um from a you know
from an economic standpoint you know so
my belief is that
um owning smaller pieces of a business
but in a lot of businesses um is a
is kind of the most um responsible
kind of thing to do um so that's one
thing the second thing is
um you know i believe fundamentally that
the internet
is is have as undergoing of a complete
makeover right now
from um broadcast to niche
and what i mean by that is um
there's you know in the facebook era i
was all about and twitter really er it
was all about broadcast get things out
there
these big social platforms and now
there's these
you know people find the refuge and
fortnite worlds and discord
chats and imessage groups and slack
communities and
all these like kind of virtual places
um and that's and people are willing to
spend money
to to access those zones and
and they also get a lot of meaning for
you know meaning just being in those
places
um so you know the reason i started
late checkout was because
i said to myself i want to start a
product studio i want to
build as much as possible
during this time um you know because i
believe that this is the renaissance
time
for for so many and i don't want to
create you know
one art piece during the renaissance
right i want to create
as many different pieces as possible so
what late checkout does is number one
it's a product studio
number two um we acquire internet uh
profitable internet communities
so we'll literally find businesses um
you know and acquire them um and and the
third thing we do is we have a few
clients um you know and we have
basically an agency business where we
help you know companies like um
companies like tick tock companies like
warner brothers music
just figure out what does community
really mean
all right and so when you are doing this
kind of transitioning back and forth
between an investor seat
an entrepreneur's seat an acquirer seat
and an
advisor seat you get a really holistic
uh view of consumer social type
companies and so where are the areas
right now
that are the obvious things that are
working right so
i know you're a growth advisor to tick
tock so that's kind of working maybe
talk a little bit about that and then
what other areas or companies
do you see kind of working most people
would say yes that makes sense and
that's an obvious thing
yeah i mean right now i'm kind of just
obsessed with
um just
how big platforms have gotten
and how horizontal these platforms have
gotten
and how vulnerable these platforms have
gotten so i'll give you examples
um zoom we're on a zoom meeting right
now
it's you know being used for a thousand
ten thousand different use cases
um now if we sat down and we kind of
like jammed on it i'm sure we can figure
out a thousand businesses
where we can look at zoom and we can
target at a vertical
and we could put a paywall up and we
could do some content distribution
that's free
um and then we can bring influencers on
and and we can make a million dollars
and
i bet we can launch a few you know
one of those a month and if we tried
that's that's zoom
linkedin linkedin launched stories
yesterday i think
linkedin stores like are you kidding me
um i think there's a massive
there's like so much opportunity to look
at linkedin
and and trying to figure out um where
they're
most vulnerable and there's certain
people doing elements of this
some people are looking at the um you
know
looking at it from the corporate
hierarchy uh
you know organizational behavior kind of
thing where they're like
um you know putting you know you
creating linkedin for their internal
companies and stuff like that
some people are creating professional
slack communities and
putting paywalls on it um
again a bunch of ways to make a lot of
money
um by just chipping away at linkedin
because
you know i don't really want to live in
a world where linkedin is the
end-all and be-all of professional
networking i think we can do better than
that
um and then reddit you know reddit
um is surging in traffic
um it's become a place where it's
you know it's you can easily find like
really great content
and feel like you're a part of a
community and the beauty
what i love about reddit is you can
actually see through these products like
redditlist.com and redditmetrics.com
which basically gives you an insider
information in
information as to like what subreddits
are trending
what's happening and basically
opportunities like inside
info basically opportunities where you
can actually go and create and unbundle
it unbundle certain
subreddits and create businesses around
it
um that's where i'm spending most of my
time thinking about
vulnerabilities yeah and i guess part of
this
is when you talk about unbundling reddit
right let's walk through kind of an
example so uh there's a subreddit it's
exploding
and it's in some niche industry right or
interest
you're not talking about going and
rebuilding reddit's functionality for
that industry what you're talking about
is potentially building ancillary or
complementary products for that industry
building other types of services for
those types of people
but you've identified hey there's a
group of people that are all
coalescing around this one idea and it
is growing fast
in both size and engagement and
therefore i know that if i build the
right thing
i can expose this community to it and
i'm likely to build a business that ends
up being successful right
exactly so i'll give you an example so
you know one of the sp one of the things
we do at late checkout is every week
ever you know all the people on the
product and design team
think about one subreddit and spend time
in in one subreddit
and they come up with an idea to how to
unbundle it so
recently i did this and what i you know
i was in
basically a ride-sharing subreddit and
it's growing a lot i'm in this ride
sharing subreddit
and i keep seeing that they're
referencing this dude named the
rideshare guy
like who the hell is this guy so i go to
his website i do some poking around it's
a blog
he also has a podcast but it's some guy
who basically gives tips and tricks
around how to make more money um as an
uber and lyft driver
simple enough the guy's making seven
figures
on on this on this blog okay and it's
it's literally like i think it's a
wordpress blog it's like super simple
and he's
creating good content but you know the
question there
is you know is there an opportunity to
you know extract that value and display
it in maybe a more interesting way
um you know and and trying to really you
know
understand what are people asking for
and why do they
why are they flocking to this to this
website um that's what i'm talking about
i'm not talking about like you know i
think what a lot of people when i say
unbundling of reddit
um a lot of people think of it as like
okay i'm gonna go create like
a reddit but for like uber drivers and
it's like no
because uber drivers might not need that
and they probably could do that very
well on facebook groups reddit what i'm
talking about is
how do you figure out what what do they
need
and what is the tool that you can create
um or the network that you can create
to serve them and so what are some
ideas there in terms of in that writing
uh the the
ride sharing subreddit obviously you can
take that guy's information you could
put it into a book or other format and
kind of resell it
um you know bundle it up make it look
nice but it almost feels like you can go
even further
and you can create
chat specific uh type stuff for ride
sharing
you can create all of the video live
streaming
you could sell uh any sort of um
kind of video camera uh hardware that
they end up putting inside the cars
you could create an entire brand around
like hey here's your starter pack
right and that starter pack gives you um
you know whatever they hang on the back
of the
seat and a sign and a camera and you
know
all of this type of stuff like there are
10 to 20 businesses
just to serve the people who are doing
ride share driving
right right right there and now you've
found the customer and so
i want to extrapolate that out and get
to this idea of like
what you're supposed to as you're
finding the customers and then building
the product for the customer
right you and i've talked about this
before we're seeing that not just an
unbundling of
reddit we're seeing that across the
world right if you look at kim
kardashian
kylie uh kanye west same thing they
built massive audiences then figured out
what's the product that should build to
then go sell to this audience
so maybe talk a little bit about how you
think on that
kind of reversal instead of building a
product and going find customers now
finding the customers first and then
building the product
yeah and so the way i think about it is
like
how do you start with the community and
then build the software versus
starting with the software and then
building the community
and so for example
with this uber driver ride sharing
example
i actually created oh and then the other
beauty is
it's ridiculously cheap to
to design and create products either
through no code or low code
so one of the things you know i did to
just test this idea
out you know we tested a bunch of ideas
in this ride sharing component
uh uh this right turning uh subreddit
but one of the things i did was it's
like oh hey
what are they saying what do they say
what are they actually saying the
subreddit they're saying that they want
ways to make more money
and they're saying actually that they
want to be surrounded by
uh other you know uh people and ride
sharing so i was like okay
what if we can create an app that was
basically like a party
line but for uber drivers and
you know i posted it and it went
completely viral on
on on the rideshare subreddit and it's
like okay maybe there's a business there
right maybe maybe there's a business
there and i think
you know i actually think that people
you know we don't have an audience in in
right in that in in ride sharing
um so we have to go and like lease it
and like create those relationships with
like the mods the moderators and all
these people
but i actually think that people who
have ought have audiences right now
the influencers the micro influencers of
the world
actually have like an unfair advantage
and if they can actually partner with
people
like late checkout who can actually
create products
then there's a huge opera that is a huge
opportunity there because what like
you know if i look at you pomp it's like
okay you have all this credibility
and you know in the bitcoin and crypto
world
um and the question is like you know how
could you
you know i mean it's it's age-old like
endorsing it's michael jordan made most
of his money from nike it's it's dr dre
made most of his money from from
beats it's but there's not enough
happening
in in the digital product realm and
my whole point of this thing is that
literally
literally if you go into reddit and you
go into facebook groups
they're serving it to you on a platter
they're telling you what
what they want well i'll make it even
more tangible right so
uh take joe rogan which many people know
who he is and he's got this massive
podcast
and when he did the deal with spotify
everyone was freaking out and they're
like oh my god joe rogan sold out like
he only made 100 million dollars like
he could have easily uh done other
things to make money
right and yes that's true uh some of
those things included
sell his own advertising rather than go
through the agencies and he would have
made more
uh some of it would have been uh
introduced subscriptions so people pay
him for
whether it's extra episodes or he just
brings the whole thing behind a paywall
whatever that was
but i kept going back to this idea of no
the most
profitable thing that joe rogan could
have done is started
companies and then kicked all the
advertisers out and taken his own
companies
and pushed them through his distribution
and said to people
you know take uh traeger grills is uh
one of his sponsors
if he went to them and said hey this is
what we're gonna do i will i will
continue to advertise
a grill but i want to set up a legal
entity with you we're 50 50 partners and
we're going to create the joe rogan
grill
and when we create that grill i'm going
to push it through my distribution
and i own 50 of the equity of this
product you own the other 50 percent
let's go make a bunch of money
he would make more money by doing that
than simply just doing the advertising
for trader kills
right because he owns the equity of a
business and then he could just go down
the line
every single product that he has as an
advertiser
he could simply just recreate do the
exact same advertising only it's his
brand versus somebody else's
and he'd make a killing he would make
billions of dollars doing this i think
compared to just tens of millions of
dollars in the advertising firm
yeah i think i think you know creators
don't understand the value of their
brand equity
i think that's what it comes down to um
because it's really hard to
value it like how you know there's not a
website you can go and say
like at pomp what am i worth what am i
worth for
cereal what am i worth for you know
different
different uh you know verticals
i think that you know jo rogen did a bad
deal
frankly um i think
um and and i bet he's probably feeling
it today i mean
obviously he got he you know listen it's
he got what is it 100 million dollars
it's great you know that's awesome but i
think that
he definitely he definitely didn't get
as much as
i think he deserved and spotify is the
one who when you look at that deal
it's less about like is it a good deal
bad deal in my situation it's just that
spotify got much more value out of it
than joe rogan did
right because the deal would be fine if
he got paid
half a billion dollars or a billion
dollars right you know it's just that
the um the difference of value transfer
there was definitely in spotify's favor
which is that's just the way deals
happen uh what else are you guys
thinking about
or um kind of playing around with uh
with like checkout
what are some other ideas you have or
areas that you're interested in
yeah i mean i have a list of ideas
that i always have that i can pull up
and we can just
talk about them um all right
that's cool and we could just pick a
random one
um i literally have hundreds of ideas
um in the in here um
and i'm gonna i'm just gonna literally
spin the wheel
and just pick one random one that comes
up and then you can tell me
what you think what are your thoughts
and some of these are just like
also like had a couple glasses of wine
and you write an idea
all right let's hear him okay
um boom
well this came out of so uh the
the subreddit battle stations so
everyone's working from home um or a lot
of people are working from home i should
say
especially knowledge workers um have you
know are starting to want to like
have dope setups um one of the big
you know trending subreddits right now
is this battle stations where people are
taking pictures of their setups and
posting it so the question pomp is there
a business
um to create that leverages
something like battle stations yeah this
is why i love talking to you so
i've been telling people i'm waiting for
somebody to come pitch me
uh i call it wfh or wfhbox.com
justworkfromhomebox.com
go on to a website pay 500 bucks three
days later a box shows up and it is
a camera a microphone headphones
a backdrop an instruction manual
whatever
and it is like level one of getting
started with work from home
in terms of all of the equipment you
need spend twelve hundred dollars and
you get level two
and go all out and spend you know three
thousand dollars and you get level three
for example
and something just that simple of
arbitraging
somebody who knows nothing and doesn't
want to spend the time to research
what's the best microphone what's the
best headphones what's the best camera
what's the best light you know all that
kind of stuff
with i already know what the best light
microphone headphone
you know whatever it is and how much
does it cost oh it cost me 250
to get all of the equipment put it in a
box for 500 bucks
run some paid ads get it in front put it
in this you know battle station
subreddit
like it's not very hard to find that
traffic right now right and so
again it's not going to be a billion
dollar business but could you make you
know one two three million bucks
a year absolutely i think
yeah and that's the other thing i just
wanted to highlight which is you don't
for a lot of these like unbundling ideas
you don't need venture capital
to get started i know the vcs won't like
hearing that but like
you know there's nothing wrong with
starting a business and doing
you know a few million bucks a year and
making money and just and then that's it
and it's a self-contained business it's
a vending machine you've built a vending
machine
you create value and that's that's it
i completely agree what type of business
would you build for battle stations
um so battle station so i think
for for me um
i would do a high-end
so i would try to create an invite-only
community that's luxury battle station
so basically i would
i would cr you know people like
aspirational brands
and um especially with battle stations
like it's basically like porn for these
people
like they're they're going on and
they're like salivating like wish i wish
i had that i wish i had that
um i would try to source some of the
most expensive
um kind of
uh some of the most expensive like
mahogany
like beautiful sort of desks and like
these screens that are like zoom
enabled and stuff like that and i'd
bundle it all up i would do all drop
shipping
um and i'd create like a feed on top of
it that just shows these like beautiful
pictures um
and i try to figure out a way to make it
a monthly subscription because i'm just
obsessed with monthly
subscriptions so um maybe every month i
get some sort of box
at my workstation where we partner with
different brands so like
that's you know i'm just we're just
riffing here but you know
brands want access to that real estate
battle station real
real estate and maybe that's the real
idea right like maybe it's like
how do you how do you you know send like
little
cactuses or succulents or
different part different partner
products and and stuff like that
stickers and stuff like that
um something there i love it
what's another idea all right spin the
wheel
okay um okay so this just came out of an
insight
so 15 of people actually get jobs
through job boards
eighty-five percent are mostly through
friends what's a product to connect you
to your friend uh what's a product to
connect you
um to jobs via your network
i think right now if you said what's the
one job board somebody should create
i would immediately go and create a
sub stack support
job board which basically would say
there's a bunch of people creating like
sub stacks and kind of these personal
media companies and stuff and i would
basically create a job board where they
could post
either one-off tasks or actual you know
part-time or full-time roles
and they could say hey uh i need an
editor for example
right and so there's a opportunity for
editors to either do it in a freelance
capacity or actually get a job
working for some of the most successful
ones and you could eventually expand
this to
all of these different creator-type
platforms where people are just being
incentivized and given the tools to
create those personal media companies
they're going to need help right they
literally can't do it by themselves
and so you can just play matchmaker
again it doesn't have to be massive
but you could easily build a bill or a
million dollar business
simply by uh creating an interface where
people could post the opportunities
and other types of folks who want to
support those creators come in and find
jobs
uh so toby said something toby from
shopify said something i really like
which is
um arming the rebels and it's all about
this whole new passion economy
and it's about you know arming the
rebels and giving them the tools
necessary they need to succeed
so i think this idea is i mean it's
perfect right like
there's this whole new economy that's
being created um
and people need help i think it's now
it's like how do you verticalize it
specific for this use case
you know someone might want an article
to be ghost written
so how do you allow them to like you
know create
anonymous anonymous posting right i have
a sub stack with 20 to 30 000
subscribers i'm looking for
xyz um this is like
i mean this is definitely 500 000 plus
business
like like pretty instantly completely
agree
what is uh one business that you think
somebody could start in a weekend like
if i gave you right now
ten thousand dollars you only had the
weekend to build it
and you think that within 12 months it
could do
five plus million dollars
what what's that look i would think
about unbundling fiverr which is like a
big sleeper
you know fiverr like the five dollar
marketplace yep um
they're starting to get really big and
and it's cool because it had there's a
habit there
um so it's like you know it's more than
five dollars now but five ten twenty
dollars for
social media posts or something like
that i would just create a marketplace
targeted targeted at something
you know maybe it's just like uh
we create tick-tock videos for you and
um then i would do and then i just take
out a bunch of facebook ads
and i would i'd basically go consistent
and i would create a bunch of different
i'd basically unbundle fiverr in like
five or ten verticals
i would uh market it specifically to
that those audiences
i'd pick verticals or services that are
growing and new
so that's why i use tic tac as an
example like what are things
your sub stack is another great example
what are things that you can do
and then you and use marketing direct
paid ads
on facebook to drive it that's an easy
one
what about you um
i'm really obsessed right now with uh
[Music]
figuring out ways to take creators
i would reach out to like 10 creators
that have uh large audiences and i would
say to them
all right we can do drop shipping of a
specific product we're gonna put your
brand on it we're gonna treat you like
the
uh historically athletes have been uh
treated and we're going to sell these
products
but i wouldn't do something like
merchandise like that's too easy
and it's too kind of saturated i think
instead what i would do is i would
create
um really unique hybrid products
so uh a very simple one that uh that
i've seen
is jaco wilnick sells a poster
that has his like the ten rules of a uh
warrior kid i think it's called and it's
literally just like a really nicely done
poster that's got these ten kind of
rules of how to live your life for kids
and he signs it sells it for 250 bucks a
pop
and i can't remember if it's just the
poster or it comes with a frame as well
but like how hard is it to create the
poster and the design and all this kind
of stuff it's not that hard well why is
it sell for 250 bucks it's because
you've got somebody who's got a massive
audience and people want to
uh kind of be associated with and so you
could go and replicate that and create
an entire poster business with creators
and maybe you don't sell them for 250
bucks but could you sell them for 100
and just you know replicate it over and
over and over again it cost you nearly
nothing you drop ship it
and you've got you know a couple million
dollar business pretty easily i think
you got me thinking about um a website i
i saw today called bonsai mirai
have you seen that one no what's that so
basically it's this dude who is like big
in the bonsai community
and he charges you 30 bucks a month to
watch him trim
bonsai trees and i
looked into the traffic and the guy is
let's just say the guy
is i mean definitely seven to eight
figure
revenue from it so the
so the question i have is what are other
verticals
where you can find the guy
or the girl um
create a live stream that someone create
a subscription around
that people be willing to pay for
i've always thought that
there will be a live stream subscription
service that will replace
daytime tv or the talk shows
and if you think about um
who that audience is it's moms
right it's mom sitting at home and if
you say hey it's 10 20 bucks
and we're basically gonna live stream
and talk about
gossip right i mean just entertainment
news and and kind of all that stuff
i think there's a lot of people who
would pay uh when you're you're
diving into an industry you know exists
two you already know those big
businesses in terms of
uh you know the magazines and all that
kind of stuff three is you know that the
people are sitting at home
and then four is they've got disposable
income and so
you know you're solving kind of this
problem of loneliness you're solving
access to information
and if you could even build it more
community than just live stream
and now all of a sudden they can
actually engage with you it's just
you're taking the quote-unquote gossip
right when rather than go to
uh go on a walk with your girlfriend
right for a mom like my mom used to
go and she wouldn't go on a walk but she
would like go meet up with a friend
and they would sit and they would talk
about you know oh did you see this
actress did this or this actor did this
or whatever
if all of a sudden that you had a
community where you could go do that
with all the people in the world
and then of course as you spend more
time on it you get locked in because
you're actually
getting a community you're learning who
the members are you can somehow you know
hey do i want to talk to my friends
today or do i want to like meet new
people
you can build a whole little product
around it and at 10 20 bucks a month
uh where else are they gonna go gossip
i think there's probably an opportunity
to do like
an hq trivia type thing
with gossip for moms paid
monthly with some sort of community
aspect
of course i mean look one of the biggest
businesses that i've been really
surprised by
is uh the games right all of these
uh things like um uh what do you mean
and you know you talk to like the guys
who run um that business
it's a massive business and then they've
created you know six seven other games
off of it and all this kind of stuff and
so like
whether it's a digital product or a
physical product the whole idea of
entertainment and games i think kind of
like went to the wayside and like
zynga and all these guys people were
like oh like that's over
it's still a massive massive business
yeah but i think 100 i agree and but
also like going back to your like
you know sort of like magazine
mom sort of insight which is
you're right like think about all those
like like the view right
like how do you modernize the view
that's the question
i think so i think there is a big big
business there
uh and especially if you kind of seat it
the right way
uh i just think people will uh will
spend time um
you know watching in the live stream how
long does the banzai guy
live stream for do you know
i think oh 30 minutes so you pay 30
a month to watch him cut the tree for 30
minutes a day
a week a week 30 minutes i think it's 30
minutes a week
but you also get access to videos
like so think about like a master class
you know that's what's also happening is
the master classification of everything
which is kind of another thread which is
interesting so you have to like and
that's what people that's what founders
that's what i encourage people to do is
to map all the stuff out
it's like hey what listen i know nothing
about bonsai trees
literally um but like people know
a lot of stuff about you know weird all
kinds of whatever they're into
so it's like okay how do you look at
master classifying it how do you look at
like you know unbundling reddit in that
you know go to all those places and see
where you can fit yourself in
completely agree what's up what's
another idea you have on uh on the list
um let's see
spin of the wheel um okay this one's
this one's kind of dumb but uh oh it's
just hilarious
the uh people so my you know my
brother's a doctor he
he was working in the corona ward when
it was it was really bad up here
and you know i was like hey would you
ever go on a
like you know would you fly would you
fly and how would you fly
today in 2020 and he was just like yeah
like i'd wear
a mask and i'd wear maybe maybe a face
shield and i would i would
you know get rid of my i would basically
as soon as i leave the plane i would
like basically throw out my clothes
so the product is a flight suit for
flying i literally
uh got on a plane in the last four
months one time
uh and there was a guy who had a hazmat
suit on and like wasn't kidding like had
the gloves the the mask the face shield
like he was
i didn't know if he was there to check
on people or if he was a passenger
right right and so like i don't know if
it would have to be
that extreme but could you see people
basically putting something on over
their clothes that
at least if it didn't look horrible to
get on the plane
sure why not absolutely and i think it i
actually like the idea of it
being somewhat extreme because i think
that like will go viral
and like you know i think that's really
important
and then like okay you know the question
is like okay well how big of a business
could that be you know well you know
is that five million dollars in revenue
10 million revenue well
you can actually a that's significant
and b
like what are other products that people
are gonna need in this new world
like that you can expand into so you're
building a brand
um so yeah maybe you do hand sanitizer
maybe you do mask maybe you do this
maybe you do that
um so i yeah i think there might be
something there
uh tell everyone about the haircut
product because i i realized that we
haven't talked about this and
and this will uh for those that are
saying like oh these guys are just
talking about ideas but they have no
clue what they're talking about maybe
explain what you did with the haircut
thing during
the beginning of uh quarantine sure so
uh pretty simple um sort of viral idea
called you probably need a haircut.com
built
in under 48 hours no code
um you know google domain
wix editor like literally that you know
nothing nothing okay
um and uh and basically built a
marketplace for people who
need haircuts um and uh
and then stylists actually people of
color were stylists who were out of work
and who wanted to give haircuts um and
we launched it and kind of went to sleep
and in the morning we woke up and it was
like everywhere on the today show abc
fox npr literally millions of people
went
to visit this website and still continue
to visit this website to book
haircuts because they don't feel either
their barber shops or
salons are closed or they just don't
feel safe and they're just like you know
what i want my girlfriend to help cut my
hair
it's fine um and uh
it's been it's been cool there's like
it's it's still super popular
and the beauty of this is like you're
not joking when you say that it took you
48 hours because of the way you built it
right like like this is this was not
something where people how do you get on
the today show well
it's because you lined up a lot of
things and we should caveat it with like
you have done a lot of work and that was
the product of
decade plus of experience expertise all
that kind of stuff
but other people could have built the
exact same
thing so it's not the building that's
the hard part it's
thinking through what is the product
that people will find valuable and how
do i actually go ahead and launch it
yeah and i think i think it's that some
of the nuances like some of the things i
was thinking about
i think i think naming is underrated
like
picking a really a name that people will
remember is really important so like you
probably need a haircut
brings a smile to people's faces so that
was really important
um we did a video like when you go to
the website we got
like a celebrity to do the video for us
um and or you know he has a show on the
food network
um so he has a community so he brought
his initial community to like
use the product again little thing um
and then we kind of just worded the
product in like
plain english you know just like super
simple
you go on you get it um and
that was it i love it
what's one thing that you've tried that
didn't work
um well there's thousands of things i've
tried and didn't work
um you know i think
i i helped start something called
wall street survivor which was a
it is the most popular financial well
the most popular stock market game on
the internet to this day actually
um but and and
and then i i added this component to it
which is like kind of like a code
academy for investing so basically
you would like get fake cash and you'd
go on this like sort of missions and
you'd learn about the stock market this
is like post 2008 when like
people's net worth dropped 50 and
they're like why so we're just like hey
financial literacy needs to be a thing
um you know the problem is we raise
venture for it
and um what we didn't realize is that
like
we we became the biggest like 85 percent
of the top u.s business schools use it
as a part of a finance curriculum they
pay for the product
the it is still the largest stock market
game but like
the market is it caps out
um so my mistake there was
basically raising you know raising too
much money
um and
[Music]
and picking it's okay if the market is
capped
um but it's not okay it's okay if you're
self-funded but it's not okay
if you you have other people's money
makes sense uh before before we wrap up
um what is kind of the benefit or the
inflection point caused by
no code so first of all what is no code
for those that don't know
and then kind of how has that changed
this idea of ideating and quickly
launching products
so you know the no code low code
movement or has really taken off over
the last few years and it's basically
the set of services that
allow anyone to create a website or hat
with no technical skills and
it's products like webflow you know it's
products like squarespace etc
and what it allows anyone in the world
to do
is have an idea being not technical
um buy a domain literally
that's it eight ten bucks a year um get
some storage for a few bucks
a month and you know for the price of
two or three lunches um you basically
have a startup
um and what it allows
the reason it's changed the game is it
allows you to test
you can test like i would encourage
someone listening to literally test
one idea a day like you can literally if
you have the ideas and we've talked a
lot about
a lot of opportunities between linkedin
between zoom between
you know reddit um all these big
platforms
like if you can come up with a night you
can literally launch an idea a day
um and you don't have to raise venture
capital
you don't have to go to stanford
computer science and
and learn stuff um and
i think a good place actually to learn
about the only you know there are some
tutorials on no code
you can go to like makerpad um to learn
about it which is like an educational
resource around it
um but yeah it's completely democratized
the playing field i love it
i asked same two questions to everyone
as uh
we end first being what's the most
important book you've ever read
uh the road ahead by bill gates
why i got it when i was
when my first day in the seventh grade
or second day in the seventh grade in
the library at the school i was at
um i just randomly came across it i
opened the book and i just skimmed
through the pages and and i ended up
staying there like the whole day and i
read
basically read the book um and basically
i'm not a huge bill gates fan
or whatever microsoft fan or whatever
but he basically outlined the future
he basically said he he predicted
cryptocurrency he protected
uh predicted like video conferencing
predicted basically how the internet
would work with social networking and
this was in 1994 or something
so he he really knew where the world was
going
and i closed the book and i was like
damn you know
you know i i i'm gonna go and this is i
want to use technology like this is
you got to be crazy not to be building
on top of technology it's completely
you know as a canadian i always felt
like an outsider
looking in you know because canada 90 of
people live on
within 45 miles of the us border where
like kind of outsiders looking in at
like
you know the exciting you know we're on
like for example montreal's on the new
york border like new york city is right
there
um but it i was just like wow now i can
talk you know
i can talk to anyone so that was the
most influential book
love it um more fun question
aliens believer or non-believer
definitely a believer definitely
believer
why i mean i i've met humans who are who
are kind of alienated
and i'm kind of like are you an npc like
are you
not you know like are you a real person
um
i think in all seriousness i mean it's
like it's one of those things where it's
like
when you when you see the picture of
the milky way versus you know as one
just one galaxy and there's infinite
galaxies like you got to be
i'm not a betting man but like you've
you gotta bet on it right
so that there there has to be out there
and
um you know i wonder if they have their
own version of sub stack or their own
version of reddit so
that's that's what i'm looking to learn
more about
that's an awesome answer you get to ask
me one question to end it what question
do you have
why bang bang i actually don't know
that's a horrible answer i said it one
time
and uh i can't remember where i said i
think it was on a youtube video
and everyone was like bang bang bang
bang bang bang you know and just went
nuts
and so then i said it again and then
next time i knew like it was just a
thing
um and uh i've actually had people like
come up to me at a conference and be
like you know bang bang i'm like all
right that's weird
uh i've had uh john nigerian
from cnbc and and did a bunch of trading
uh when i he came on i was like bang
bang and i don't think he knew that i
said that all the time
so he immediately responds with bang
bang and he starts doing his finger guns
at me and i was like all right man
this is getting out of control but uh
it's here to stay it's not going
anywhere so good i love it
yeah well and also it's a thing um
in hindsight it actually is helpful uh
somebody sent me a clip um i think it
was gary vaynerchuk maybe
maybe somebody else can't remember but
uh they were starting all their videos
with like a noise
right and they were trying to like
basically like audio brand
their videos with that noise and so like
in hindsight like
okay you start off every single thing
with this noise it just happens to be
you don't need editing because it's just
my mouth
right but like it has some of the
similar effects so like
i'll take it for you know it's one of
these things where like i didn't think i
was
having a master plan but if it works it
works
i mean when you open up i think it was
steve jobs who did this when you open up
a
an apple computer there's the c major
chord
that that happens the dong and i think
like
those nuances like the bang bang nuances
nuance or the c major nuance is what
makes brilliant products brilliant
and memorable and you
the truth is most people don't probably
don't even remember that you bang bang
or that there's a c major chord but like
they know that they enjoyed their
experience and and
that's what matters couldn't agree more
man
all right where can people find you on
the internet
they can find me on twitter at greg
eisenberg
my name um for my thoughts
or they're up there and then if you want
my deeper thoughts i
started a sub stack so you can check it
out at late checkout.substance.com
awesome all right sir thank you so much
we're going to do this again
i had too much fun so you're on the hook
to do it again for sure
well thanks man i appreciate it